[Music]
life for my kind wasn't always this way
there was a time when no animals lived
on land
all life was in the ocean the oceans
where all of us animals got us start
more than half a billion years ago this
is where all animal body types or phyla
a scientist call them first evolved
[Laughter]
you know they are more than 30 animal
phyla but only a handful of major ones
had what it took to do something
completely daring step out of the ocean
and onto dry land so which of these
land-dwelling phyla first invaded the
land was it me and my mollusk friends
with our amazing Mantle's and single
foot perhaps a chordate crowd with their
notochord segmented muscles and big bony
skeletons or maybe those lonely annelid
worms with their powerful ringed bodies
[Music]
what did the arthropods first make
landfall with their little flexible
suits of armor their exoskeleton ah yes
the octopods from crustaceans to
millipedes spiders to insects the
arthropods outnumber all animals on land
so what's a secret that exoskeleton is
key but here's the real kicker jointed
appendages
they're like little living Swiss Army
knives and Tennie
multiple mouth parts and obscene number
of legs if you ask me there's one group
of arthropods the insects that really
rule the land three body parts six legs
and an annoying tendency to take over
[Music]
you
sure they have to molt to grow but that
doesn't seem to pose a problem the
insects even invented the first wings
and conquered the skies oh well so what
if Arthur pots were the first to reach
land and invent flight a hundred million
years before the rest of us so what if
they pollinate crops around the world
and make up 75% of all land animal
species and that for every single human
there's 200 million of them sure those
leggy arthropods may still be in the
lead when it comes to conquering land
but we still rule in the sea there are
more species of mollusks in the ocean
than any other animal phylum
[Music]
we're just getting started up here on
land
besides the seas are rising just give us
some time who knows we'll end up ruling
this ocean planet
[Music]
you